family members say the burial for
congressman Elijah Cummings of Maryland
will be private on Friday there was a
large public celebration of Cummings
life two former presidents were among
the thousands of mortars in his native
Baltimore here's Jeff Pegues for 40
years Elijah Cummings would come to new
psalmist Baptist Church to find strength
though is celebrating his life including
past presidents congressional colleagues
and presidential contenders said it was
his strength of character that made him
so special you know as president I knew
I could always count on Elijah being
honorable and doing the right thing
former President Bill Clinton who worked
with Cummings during his time in the
White House spoke of the bond the two
men shared I love every minute ever
spent with him every conversation we
ever had Cummings the son of
sharecroppers rose from humble
beginnings in Baltimore to become the
chairman of the powerful House Oversight
Committee where he led several
investigations into the Trump
administration like the Prophet our
Elijah could call down fire from heaven
like that Old Testament prophet he stood
against corrupt leadership of King Ahab
and Queen Jezebel Maya Cummings the
congressman's Widow acknowledged that
President Trump's personal attacks on
Cummings and the city of Baltimore which
he called a rat-infested City had taken
a toll they were trying to tear him down
and we needed to make sure that he went
out with the respect and the dignity
that he deserves
there were several republican colleagues
and friends of Congressman Cummings here
people he'd done battle with on Capitol
Hill a sign of just how popular and
respected he was or CBS's morning
Saturday Jeff buguese Baltimore